when my wife and i need alone time we
tell the kids oh we tell the kids that
we're going camping
yeah slang word
for he you know he likes this big screen
stuff and this acting and he's loving it
and he's thinking maybe get out of
football and become an actor um you have
any advice for this guy of course i got
advice for kurt the first thing i'm
going to say is kurt you're not going to
make it okay
that's what he was told by if you become
a billionaire what will be your
billionaire quirk you know some people
like like someone going to space are you
going to go space you're going to drill
the center of the earth what are you
going to do what is what is going to be
your billionaire like because when
people come billionaires they become
they're really weird yeah but those are
those
those are those are white billionaires
um
i think
uh yeah i mean
when my kid asked me for help on their
homework but i don't know the answer i
usually
say off
it's okay
what team do you hate the most in the
nfl oh god what teams i hate the most
yeah what team do you hate the most it's
an eagle fan uh you know what it's not
the team it's the fans
this it's cowboys cowboys for me yeah
it's the cowboys you know what i like
about the olympus is how they always
changing it up
make a slight change you change the
whole game like basketball at 3x3
it's a whole different game complete
different game volleyball at a beach
beach volleyball oh my god tennis at a
table
table tennis
you see me working i see you working
keep staying there boxing turn up the
heat
hot boxing
yo i'm not i'm not really sure how that
one works
recreational cav
and every time i do get wrecked okay all
right i'm picking up what you're laying
down what you're saying is you basically
add a word you change the sport that's
what i'm saying all right okay like this
like uh so you got mountain biking
mountain dew biking hmm now we got
sponsors all right dead lifting dead
body lifting right
that's a little dark but it's a team
sport yeah you see what i'm saying
shooting
right that's a white man supporter no no
no no shooting dice now that's for the
community have you always been a big
football fan
you know eli uh i see what you're doing
here it's very childish it's very
childish what you're doing okay yes eli
i've been a massive football fan there's
other words that we can use to describe
it without you emphasizing the word big
and i just wanted to tell you i see
through your mess and i'll tell you what
else i see through this fake brotherhood
that you and payton had i know the truth
you don't like each other okay i i've
been looking through the small for all
these years the gig is up boys the gig
is up nobody believes it nobody believes
it because if you did get along you'll
be sitting next to each other in the
room instead you're doing this whole
force force viral thing trying to make
the world think you're close i know
you're not even spending thanksgiving
together the fans are just unrealistic
like the fans
cowboy fans they have no grasp of
reality like it doesn't matter
how bad the team is they talk about
nothing but the days of old in the past
they don't really they don't really
grant it now it's just it's too much i
don't think i've argued with more people
in my life than cowboy
fans i have to say
i don't see the steelers making the play
i don't know why you had to go down that
long road
to get there why why don't you have to
take 45 seconds of our life that we can
never get better
to say what you just said it was an easy
answer we all knew the answer why did
you take so long and now i gotta tell
you and another thing and if you know
anything about me i'm objective and the
thing about being objective is
understanding when to apply objection so
in this case i'm gonna go down a road of
objectifying and i'm gonna let you know
what you may not
the answer is no we
no philadelphia eagles fans we're
grounded okay we are grounded we're
realistic we know we ain't won a lot we
know we don't have a lot of stuff to
talk about so we talk about the things
that we can and it's most of the time
it's what's happening now cowboys always
want to talk about what happened in 78
86 89.
i got time to talk to you about stuff
that i don't even remember get out of
here
get out of here i gotta say it's like
all parents uh all kids
you know it's it's
i don't have any that's right i think
but like your kids never think you're
cool
but
i bet if kevin hart is your dad then you
think that's cool no i'm cool you're
cool i'm cool
yeah yeah that's what i was thinking i
was like all right yes you're the
exception to that absolutely i'm cool
like right there's no question about it
i actually remind them like i said you
do know how cool your dad is i i say
that to him if kevin hart decides to
come do morning tv you said morning tv
today here i would quit yes
there's no way i would do it here today
you're putting your coffee way down
there
it's easier it's easier to get into jail
cells than it is in this place i've
never seen i've never went through more
i gave a blood sample
i gave a blood sample out there
you have to take every precaution no you
are i gave blood today i gave blood i
gave a finger i said
y'all did know i was coming right
y'all know i was coming but you've
always been fit here you are this is a
swim team how old are you were here uh i
am i am 13 13 years old there you go
that's right that's right team yeah
right there
yeah it just got rated r didn't it
ladies they got rated r when my family
doesn't laugh at my jokes i tell them oh
well that's very rare it never happened
so
i don't even know how to answer that
same time like i said and me you know
i'm 56 years old damn
i'm sorry
i'm sorry because i it was a thought no
no seriously it was a thought it was a
thought and i blurted it out
that way i'm fine okay but just
understand i didn't mean it the way it
came
we'll take a poll on how you meant it
with people here later after the show's
over but i can sit up here and honestly
say buddy that was from a place of love
got it like that
like damn you didn't if we could play it
back right now play back these are two
different dams playback in slow motion
there wasn't no i said i said there was
no like wow i said damn no you said the
word damn
do you want me to tell you how you said
it i know how i said it don't you want
me to say it back to you how i think you
said it go ahead
damn not not true fam not true fam i
said kevin i said
damn it
each time you said it now it's gotten
quieter and quieter i could barely hear
you that last time when you said it well
that means that you can barely hear the
truth
so who has the problem here
what's the problem
i'm telling you at the heart household
thanksgiving is unreal it's uh it's
festive it's conversation it's banter
it's music it's dancing it's big it's
actually one of my favorite holidays
yeah i don't cook though i'm not i'm not
what are you what's your what's your
lane my my meal like what about your
lane like you don't cook so do you greet
do you prepare the cocktails i don't do
i don't do a damn thing he's a guest
he's an honored guest you're a guest
that you're right i don't know he
arrives like margaritas
he's like uh i'm there you're that dude
i'm there like my presence
yes yes that's it what are you thankful
for me what are you thankful for me i
want to be your wife because part of the
excitement for me
is watching mark enter
the room where dinner will be happening
it's a big deal because he's like he's
like wow this is amazing i mean i you
have to show up this happens you have to
show up as if you knew nothing was going
on yeah
oh look at this this is crazy
you just play with your pants look at
this right here what's up everybody i
didn't know y'all got here
what up man come here man give me come
here give me something man look at the
spread y'all got the spread
what up joe you just speak to everybody
real loud what up joe i see you come on
man
hey kyle i didn't know you was coming
hey man home alone is one of those
movies that i know for me if it's on i'm
sitting down i'm watching the whole
thing one two whatever for you do you
remember the first time you saw it uh i
do
i was actually just coming home from a
long walk with no i don't remember it's
like wow excellent
i don't even remember just keep going
sorry
did you see how engaged
these aren't real kevin whoa i put these
on to appear smart we're going to cut
this part out
you might need i'm not going to let this
fly you might need some of these to be
smart this part won't make the interview
because you're my friend do you want to
see if it makes you appear smart they
match your they match your suit put a
star next to this part yeah because it's
not going to make me try these
look how smart you're going god damn
whoa
professor hart not a comedy good wow
could you do something for me yes sir
could you pick up your wine glass and do
that pick up a wine glass can a cherry
get popped in a picnic and i'm not a
combinator huh come on now don't do this
to me cause that's what you
whoa
oh my god
i don't think i love a person more man i
think i love personal